what have you got
for you bro best the night city has
stopped
and that would be the most no
respect geeked out turned up virtue you
ever seen man i'm talking like
transcendental
where's it from you got a license for
exclusive distribution in night city
come on man ain't nobody bothered with
that [ __ ]
know why cause stuff i got way too legit
to be legit
feel me
what's on the virtue real feeling
neurons shredding
high octane transitional
adrenaline pumping [ __ ] yo and your mom
will blow us low bruh
you gotta trust me on this
all right you got my attention yeah
i knew you couldn't resist virtue's
all yours a couple more eddies you could
use my plate
no need i've got my own wreath
of course you do it's probably top shelf
latest firmware too right you see
this virtue is approaching vintage grade
i doubt you'll be able right
you should have told me that before you
took my eddies
you're right you're right i forgot but
listen
you can use my setup ain't nobody
trust me oh yeah what's next
using your toothbrush borrowing your
underwear give me my eddies back
now damn man homeboy's got
anger management issues
try ripping me off again and i'll rip
out your [ __ ] optics
behind
oh
oh